Jerry Springer let me say a couple of
words I um I didn't watch The Jerry
Springer Show a lot but I watched it
enough to know what was going on and
whenever I watched it was pretty [__]
crazy I don't know why I didn't watch it
more
it seems like that would be a long time
I was almost addicted to it every day
I'd get off work and had a car with a
with a TV in it and I was like turn on
Jerry Springer turn on Jerry Springer
because he'd always be on when I got in
the car and I'd watch those people go
crazy and then eventually I was like
Robin what are you watching this is
crazy but I loved that Jerry Hardly did
anything he introduced to people they
started fighting the audience took over
rooting them on right and then the Wilco
would come out and separate the people
and then at the end Jerry would give his
final word the show debuted on August
30th 1991 and I thought it was a fun
show I just I don't know why I didn't
see more of it but
I'm sure those shows will live on and
infamy Jerry died last month from and
this is terrible pancreatic cancer the
guy had a big impact there weren't that
many TV shows you could tune in where
the guests were actually allowed to beat
each other up and hit each other
their wigs off I love it yeah
critics called it America's most
infamous guilty pleasure Jerry came on
here told me how the show developed when
he was talking with us back in 2014. the
original uh contract was for six weeks
because I was still well because I was
still doing the news ah there were 20
shows at the time this was 91 and we
were all trying to be like Oprah and go
after middle-aged Housewives and then
Ricky Lake came along Ricky Lake was
really the first show to go after the
kids and when I say kids I mean High
School College age right I just said as
a business model why are we trying to go
after Oprah and be one out of 20 let's
go after Ricky and and just be one out
of two so we decided right there the
next day from now on only young people
in the audience young people on stage
young subject matter well young people
are much more open about their lives and
crazier right so every once in a while
the show went crazy but not all the time
Jerry's life had some shocking moments
his mother gave birth to him in a subway
station in London in 1944 it was being
it was as a bomb shelter during World
War II and Jerry was born
moved to the United States when he was
five went to law school at Northwestern
was elected to the city council of
Cincinnati when he was only 27 years old
he was one of the youngest dudes at that
point but he he had to resigned three
years later when he admitted he hired a
hooker and paid her with a check
that's the best I think that's the
defining moment in Jerry's like people
never stop goofing on the dude here's
when he called into our show 1997 to
talk about it okay I was with a woman I
shouldn't have been with her and um four
years later
um she came forward no I I had I had
revealed that what I had done and I held
a press conference and said that I'd
gone to this club and that I'd been with
this woman and you mean you never got
caught
it you mean you confessed to being with
a hooker I did I did too oh yeah once
you try to Blackmail you no I never got
caught there did you try to Blackmail
you or something
well there were phone calls
uh woke up one day
one day you know what I was gonna say
you were crazy yeah really good it's a
slow news day you could understand that
I was quite taken with this whole story
you know well anyway Jerry admitted to
the whole hooker thing and then he was
re-elected to the council the following
year and he was elected mayor just two
years after that then he ran for
governor in 1982.
and he even made his prostitution Story
part of his campaign head he just he
embraced it I'm Jerry Springer and I
want to be your governor now after
sharing some specific solutions for our
unemployment and education problems in
this state looks like the nomination is
finally within grasp
which makes what I'm about to tell you
even more difficult
some nine years ago I spent time with a
woman I shouldn't have and I paid her
with a check
I wish I hadn't done that and the truth
is I wish no one would ever know
but in the rough world of politics
opponents are not about to let personal
embarrassments lay to rest
perhaps like you I'm not sure what any
of this has to do with being Governor
but maybe my talking to you about this
makes a Point Ohio is in a world of hurt
the next Governor is going to have to
take some heavy risks and face some hard
truths I'm prepared to do that this
commercial should be proof I'm Not
Afraid even of the truth
and even if it hurts
come on join me on June 8th we're going
to turn the state around Jerry always
landed on his feet
and uh this is from 2011 he told me how
he eventually moved into broadcasting I
did 10 years on city council and mayor
and then in 82 I ran for governor of
Ohio yeah I lost the very next week I
was hired by the NBC affiliate to Anchor
the news in Cincinnati I wanted to do
political commentary but they want to
meet anchors so we we had a trade-off
that I would I would agree to Anchor the
news but they would let me do a
commentary every night at the end of the
newscast yeah they were last in the
ratings
uh Channel 5 the NBC affiliate they were
bottom of the rating I mean they were
behind the Independence Station at the
time
they said let's get the mayor to be the
Anchorman exactly I see and it worked
and it worked you became the number one
Anchorman in the market yeah wow yeah
and I thought I was good at that I mean
I'm I'm not immodest in terms of what I
think I do well I think I'm a nice guy
and I think I'm bright but I'm not
talented
Jerry's show ran for over 3 000 episodes
he was on the mass singer he hosted
America's Got Talent remember he was
like one of the original hosts Regis and
Jerry Springer he was part of The Price
is Right gee I didn't know that in three
missed World pageants yeah rest in peace
Jerry Springer he was nice guy always
came on our show always uh mixed it up
with us and uh hopefully Somewhere in
Heaven right now Robin all of the angels
are chanting the following
feel